We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here is an interesting take about Donald Trump's
distraction of Joe Biden vía interruption
during the Tuesday night debate.
Take a listen.
I did.
I listened to it every day.
I really enjoy your show.
I just have one comment about the debate.
As if Trump had and then yammering and screaming
and yelling so much to Joe Biden, I think
Joe would have done a lot better.
It was hard to concentrate.
I'm surprised he didn't lose his focus more
often.
And it's hard just sitting here listening
to it and trying to keep track of what was
going on.
So that's that's my only remark.
I just wondered what you thought about that.
I think it's completely plausible that Donald
Trump, with his preconceived notion that Biden
will lose his train of thought and that Biden's
Trump's strategy.
Trump's interruptions were not just Trump
being an unhinged, petulant child, but it
was the idea that Trump thought, if I keep
interrupting, it's going to throw Joe off
his game and he's going to fall apart.
Now, I think it definitely rattled Biden early,
but once it became clear that Chris Wallace
was not going to be able to take control of
it, Joe Biden figured out what to do.
And it included at some point saying, you
know, will you shut up, man, you're a clown
and that type of thing.
At other points, just kind of powering through
Trump's interruptions.
So I do.
Anybody would be distracted by that.
If you're trying to speak coherently about
policy, as Joe Biden was trying to do, and
someone's just yammering yammering and they
won't shut up.
Anybody would get distracted by it.
I do think it was a Trump strategy.
And I think by the second half of the debate
of the debate, Joe Biden, a better handled
at the commission, now says they're going
to change some of the rules because of Trump's
interruptions during the upcoming debates.
We will see what those rule changes are.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We have a counter offer covered relief bill
presented to Nancy Pelosi by Stephen Manoogian.
We will discuss it.
We will talk about the latest bizarre legal
argument being made by Tucker Carlson's lawyers
and much more.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com.